erst im frühjahr hat unsere
kultusministerkonferenz eine so genannte
prognose lücke von einer million schüler
festgestellt wie kann man denn eine
million kinder übersehen wenn sie sind
sehr klein aber trotzdem
fakt ist bayern guckt sich die
geburtenstatistik jedes jahr an jedes
jahr viele andere bundesländer nur alle
fünf jahre oder so weil sie sich die
überraschung nicht versauen wollen
wie kann es denn sein dass die politik
es hat überhaupt so weit kommen lassen
das ist das ist wirklich die frage die
mich auf bewegt könnte man fast drüber
lachen wenn die sprechende
schlaftablette nicht zufällig präsident
der kultusministerkonferenz wäre ja
falls sie nicht wissen was das ist da
treffen sich viermal im jahr die
bildungsminister der länder und
entscheiden über die zukunft unserer
kinder
wir haben natürlich auch keinen bock
drauf das muss man sich vorstellen wie
die sechste stunde in der berufsschule
wer hat lust wer hat lust über
personalschlüssel zu reden oder
geburtenraten das niveau ist
erschreckend und den rest des tages
streiten sondern über g8 oder g9 89
[Applaus]
schlimm schlimm schlimm
tatsächlich machen sich unsere
bundesländer noch untereinander
konkurrenz und schnappen sich die
letzten lebenden pädagogen weg das lässt
für mich nur ein logischer schluss zu
nehmt den ländern endlich die bildung
weg der sie sind offiziell zu blöd für
alles rechnen können sie jedenfalls
nicht eine million kinder extremer
lehrermangel in einem so reichen land
wie deutschland ist doch wahnsinn wenn
sie darüber nachdenken ein steuer
überschuss nach dem anderen am ende
müssen wir wahrscheinlich die allgemeine
wehrpflicht wieder einführen es ist
augen zu und an deutschland denken
wirklich unfassbar wer jetzt in der not
als lehrer wird unter anderem auch der
kollege martin klempnow martin wie
konnte das denn passieren
unglaubliche geschichte welche die
verzweifelten kommunen arbeiten
inzwischen alle mit tricks habe der
letzten freitag beim feiern zwei total
nette typen kennengelernt
wir quatschen so habe spaß ich an nichts
böses
heute weiß sich die wand vom
kultusministerium wir saufen da fröhlich
und am nächsten morgen was ich am
lehrerpult auch so schnell wirst du
lehrer ja ich habe zu hause plötzlich
den ganzen schrank voller cottbus
braucht eine brille und bin alkoholiker
vielen dank auch wir haben dann können
sie doch einfach kündigen verkündigen
ach ja die haben mich verbeamtet die
arschlöcher kein sohns anspruch da kann
ich doch nicht einfach kündigen was
mache ich denn jetzt
ich weiß nichts und ich hasse kinder
immerhin die neuen kollegen sind alle
ganz nett ja wir haben hier ein
fliesenleger wir haben metzger und zwei
prostituierte
naja hilft nix dann unterrichte ich eben
ab jetzt was eigentlich geschichte muss
ich mich aber erst mal reinlesen wusstet
ihr dass deutschland mal geteilt war
verrückt endlich ich hab feierabend so
jetzt habt ihr erst mal physik bei herrn
schulz viel spaß und freizeit
unser thema heute der impuls der photon
das ist eine simple berechnen war mit
hilfe der lichtgeschwindigkeit woher und
politik auf die fresse
dr
[Applaus]